well let's get some analysis and
reaction to last night's program uh the
conservative peer and pollster lord
robert hayward is here with me a very
good morning to you
going into the show last night rishi
sunak needed a big performance didn't he
the polls were not in his favor so did
he manage to to pull off a big moment
big is possibly a slight exaggeration
but there's no question in my mind and
the vote of the audience it was the
first time that he had clearly led in a
debate and
kate got the audience to vote and there
was no question she just described it as
a clear majority for rishi well that's
interesting and liz trust similarly went
in needing at least a safe performance
she didn't want to shift the dial at all
so did she manage that oh there's no
question she she did she's improved from
the first debate where she appeared
incredibly wooden and got the lowest
ratings she's improved enormously comes
across well but the issue that dominated
last night was inevitably the bank of
england report the increase in interest
rates and that played two rush's
strengths and i think that's probably
what impacted on the audience that's
interesting that you say that because
some people might say well we associate
rishi sunak with being in charge of the
economy of the last two years you might
argue that it would count against him
yes i thought that he would have some
difficulty on in that field but there
was a sense which was conveyed in the
audience and their reaction
both on that issue and on others that he
had a grasp almost as steady as she goes
rather than let's not take a risk at
this point uh and it was it was markedly
different from previous debates and were
there any particular moments for good or
for bad that will stick with the people
who are voting for these two leaders i
think
liz has the problem it came up in a
question from the audience and then was
repeated as part of the series of pro of
questions to uh liz about things she
changed her mind on and that is this
pay for people in the north and the
midlands in terms of being a nurse or a
policeman
and i think that's going to keep coming
back because she wasn't willing to say
it was a mistake what she said was it
was interpreted incorrectly uh in other
words it's other people's fault and that
didn't resonate well with the audience
well yeah she was challenged quite hard
on that wasn't she by k burley do you
feel that she didn't give an adequate
response then because she just did say
we're not going ahead with this so why
do you keep asking me about it i'm
judging the reaction of the audience
rather than my own perception and i just
listening and
watching the audience reaction one just
felt uh that she didn't deal with it in
the same way that um
one might have done and in the same way
why do you think that rishi soon acted
particularly well last night was it
solely because there was such a focus on
the economy because of the day's news i
wouldn't say it's particularly well but
he did better than liz and i think
there's a sense that this was the first
time he'd actually got the better on him
and it it was what one might describe as
the the wild forecast of 13
inflation and a recession and all these
sorts of things
that he could as you asked just now have
been in difficulty but there was a sense
that he conveyed the message better so
that the message was got across by by
rishi in a way that it hasn't been
previously and yet there's a sense of
optimism coming from liz trust isn't
there she was keen to point out when
asked about the bank of england's
predictions she said recession isn't
inevitable
that there is the possibility to turn
things around i mean is that something
that people want to hear they want to to
feel that there could be a better way i
think
until yesterday with the bank of england
and
it's pretty dire forecasts
there was probably a sense that the
population at large was willing to go
down the path of well there is an
alternative but i think the messaging
yesterday and it's been coming from the
european central bank from the fed in
the united states is the world the free
world is in a difficult set of
circumstances
and somebody who with confidence can
answer the questions as rishi appeared
to and as one of the audience said on
that clip briefly succinctly summarize
where we are i think that was persuasive
and last time you came on this show you
talked about the impact that programs
like this can have that debates and
interviews
big interviews with the candidates can
make on the end result
do you feel that things have changed how
what kind of impact do you think they've
made liz has had the best of the last
few days no question about it with the
series of endorsements from different
major personalities i think what
happened last night was there was a stop
in terms of
um the momentum in one direction it
won't necessarily reversed it but there
is there will be this morning a
different sense of messaging
that is around um the first question to
rishi was it's inevitable you're going
to lose why don't you withdraw
and i think probably
by the end of that session
one understood why he's not withdrawing
because he had actually got some of his
messaging across but liz has done well
in the previous few days and it's
interesting timing isn't it because i
think the ballots are arriving some of
the people in the audience had had them
some hadn't most hadn't but it's
crucial timing at the moment oh
absolutely and to that extent that has
worked in rishi's favor because the
momentum was with liz no question about
it and had the ballots arrived a few
days earlier people would have completed
them i haven't received mine uh people
i've been speaking to yesterday evening
hadn't received theirs so it is
absolutely crucial
and we keep talking about this poll lead
that liz trust has rishi sunak's
supporters would say that's not what
we're witnessing
when we go out and about we're
witnessing much more support than is
reflected in the polls i mean what's
your sense of what's going on my sense
is that the polls are right up to a
point
but
you had the audience response last night
and remembering that they were an
audience from all over the country
so
there have been a lot of undecideds
and i think you may have got a fair
amount of them or them reflected in the
audience last night all the polls
although the number of undecideds has
been diminishing
um i think the audience last night
conveyed a message from the undecideds
largely
lord robert hayward always very
interesting to get your take on things
thanks so much for coming in this
morning we appreciate it